Good morning John; I love Tumblr text posts.
As they rise to the top of the most massive
slush pile in the history of the universe
getting six or even seven figures of notes.
Accumulating the endorsement of seemingly
everyone, they become almost objectively great.
Like no one could argue with their greatness.
And when I read them, I usually agree.
A nugget of insight, a fascinating explanation,
a truly daring set of puns.
Most text posts that break out into virality
are the height of a form -- a pretty weird
form, agreed, but I also like the Tumblr text
post because, like all media, they say a lot
about the culture that creates and honors
and promotes them.
And here's one that I came across quite a
while ago that kinda stuck with me, “What
I’m really terrified of is leading an average,
ordinary life with a regular job and an invariable
routine, planned holidays, an average household,
fixed responsibilities and not doing anything
different to be remembered by.”
This post has around half a million notes,
and that makes me a little worried because
John, as you have, for some reason, repeatedly
driven home over and over again, probably
because you struggle with this quite a lot
yourself, oblivion is inevitable and someday
there will be no one left to remember anything,
let alone you or me.
Being remembered forever is not a good goal
because it is not an achievable goal.
But if that argument doesn’t work for you,
take a look at me.
I am what people call successful; I've had
more than my share of interesting life experiences.
I've toured in a rock band, been written about
in the New Yorker, helped raise over 2 million
dollars for charity, Crash Course is watched
in thousands of schools, and I don’t know
if you heard about this, but recently I interviewed
the President.
So you might ask, when was it for me when
I knew that I had made it?
When was the moment when I had the success
statue and I got to put it on this shelf right
here next to Obi-Wan?
Was it when I was first recognized in public
or when we got one hundred thousand subscribers
or a million subscribers or when I was first
paying my bills with YouTube?
Which day was it when I became perpetually
satisfied and always happy?
Yeah, it was none of the days.
Here’s the thing about success, if you're
smart enough and you're dedicated enough and
lucky enough and sacrifice enough, you too
will get to find out that none of it exists.
It’s made up.
It’s just it’s not a real thing.
You get successes, but you don’t get success.
The whole of everything of it does not lie
on that arbitrary yet remarkable thing that
you did that everyone says, “Yes, that.
That counts.”
I've had those things, and they do not bring
long term satisfaction.
The satisfaction?
The joy?
That comes from solving problems and making
things.
And often times the recognition isn’t even
a necessary part of the process.
So if I have any advice for the five-hundred-thousand
people who either liked or reblogged that
text post on Tumblr, here it is: instead of
thinking about what you will and won’t accomplish
in your life, think about the problems that
you have helped solve and you will help solve
and the things that you're gonna help make
and that you've already helped make.
I don’t think I am alone in feeling like
the things that we help make and the problems
we help solve, those are the things that really
matter the things that actually affect the
world and that actually make us happy.
And maybe every person is unremarkable in
that we all make things every day.
We make happiness and we make families and
we make sandwiches and most fantastically
of all we make ourselves.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.
End screen.
And you know why we love video games so much?
Because they give us clear defined problems
to solve and value-laden achievements to unlock,
and I love it, which is why Games with Hank
officially today is back with new series “Hank
Green Plays The Sims.”
And then of course you can adjust booby size
to the beat of the music.
Meet Jimmy Carter, he is like ninety years
old, so let's go ahead and make him an old
man.
Oh good.
Sul sul Jimmy Carter.
I mean I guess we could give him emo hair.
Hahaha.
Oh no, no, what have I done!
Ohhhhh God!
You look great.
You're in great shape, Jimmy.
Leader of the free world?
That’s not a lifetime wish, Jimmy Carter.
You already got to do that.